[تصفيق]
من مصر اخت الهولنديه الى العاصمه
البحرينيه المنامه وتحديدا مسرح الدانه
حضور كبير هنا لحضور الحفل العالمي
للمايسترو اندري اريو المتخصص في الموسيقى
الكلاسيكيه وتحديدا موسيقى الفالس
[موسيقى]
لاول مره في حياتي احضر
انا دائما فوق المسرح لان انا عازف كله
فوق المسرح لاول مره احضر حظر لفنان عظيم
راقي وايد علشان انظف اذني
من خلال العالم القصور الاوروبيه الساحره
والموسيقى المليئه بالدهشه وثياب العازفين
والعازفات نقل اندريه الحضور الى عوالمه
الخاصه
[موسيقى]
عازفي الكمان بدا بالعجز مبكرا في سن
الخامسه شخصيته على المسرح تتميز بالصرامه
لكنه يتمتع في ذات الوقت بروح الفكاهه كما
يصفه محبه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
متحمسه جدا لحضور هنا ومشاهدته على خشبه
المسرح لقد شاهدته سابقا في بلد الام
هولندا ستكون ليله رائعه بكل تاكيد
لم استطع حضور حفلاته سابقا حاولت حضور
حفلاته في ايطاليا واسبانيا لكنني لم
اتمكن بسبب الظروف اخيرا استطعت حضور
حفلته في البحرين هذا العرض الموسيقي ياتي
ضمن فعاليات مهرجان ربيع الثقافه في نسخته
السابعه عشر مهرجان ينتظره اهالي مملكه
البحرين على احر من الجمر السنويا لما
يحمله من عروض موسيقيه وثقافيه متنوعه من
جميع انحاء العالم لصباح العربيه عبد
الرحمن العصيمي المنامه